what else we had that uh that Conor
McGregor he hit up that Greyhound
station and a lot of people you know I
put you know put a video on instagrams
and people were excited about it and
commented in this and that and people
saying this about Greyhound and this
about Greyhound and saying dude you
don't know what you're talking about
some people well guess what
I have gone greyhound while some of you
guys were in the Cub Scouts of the Boy
Scouts and y'all were in the woods you
know making [ __ ] you know little dog
cages out of vines and you know little
damn bamboo mailboxes and [ __ ] your boy
right here was on that greyhound and I
used to take that thing up to Natchez
Mississippi and work on my buddy's farm
and and look if you you know people
upset Conor McGregor threw a hand truck
at a bus window and broke it out well
guess what man I've thought about it
that [ __ ] happens on greyhound if you if
you eat you know what happens on
Greyhound pregnancy's menthol no outlets
urine that that nyle bro if you've been
on that all night trip the bus driver
one time he first time he dozes off he
slams on the brakes when he wakes up
because he's about to hit something and
that that big slam that's when that
toilet does that splash and it breaches
its bounce and next thing you know that
nyle
that Greyhound nyle bruh everybody's
problems they might have a needle in it
it might have a you know a little bitty
abortion in it that thing comes and I
know that's gross but that's the [ __ ]
hound boy that is the hound that is the
sewer that is the I mean it's what we
are really you know it's that gutter
right under us and that's that hound and
this and that thing comes rolling right
down them I'll and you better have your
bags and your legs clear man you catch a
disease out of that thing you know you
wake up with pinkeye in your butthole
that's the kind of I mean that's what
you can get on the hound and things
happen on there
so I want to say this if you have a
Greyhound bus I want to do a full
greyhound episode because I'm sick of
people thinking that that you know that
the everything is safe on the Hound
because I'll be honest i troll i troll
the Greyhound bus to help twitter feed
and I'm on there and you know I'll troll
them at night and find people that's
saying uh um excuse me
you know mr. shermin took us two hours
off the route to go visit his ex to go
visit a lady he met out there in Tupelo
well guess what [ __ ]
that's the Hound you think [ __ ] ain't
gonna happen on grayham what do you
think you think you're in Italy things
aren't real French on grayham Frings
things aren't real French things are a
little bit more Amsterdam a little bit
more Haiti you know a little bit more
Kingston you're not getting French on
greyhound people ain't nobody's [ __ ]
with champagne nobody could spell
champagne Greyhound is where things go
off you could catch a [ __ ] gram you
know Greyhound is where you know some of
them a driver pull over [ __ ] leave
y'all because he got to make a court
date and that's the kind of [ __ ] that
happens so if you have a greyhound story
because so many of them came in on my
Instagram feeding on my Facebook feed
I'm gonna put together a full greyhound
episode so if you have a greyhound story
that happened to you I want you to hit
the hotline I'm gonna do the biggest
baddest G hound breakdown that's ever
hit America and not to mention the only
one because I've been on greyhound man
nobody took me to here and drop me off
there I took hound okay I've had a dude
come up to me on greyhound and say look
but he's like look man I'm gonna he he
goes look man I'm gonna blow you or I'm
gonna suck your dick and I was like dude
that's the same thing bro and you're an
idiot and no because I've been on there
man I've seen to do get on there just
fresh out of prison by two grams of
cocaine
on the bus and by the next stop get
arrested and take him back to prison
dude was out of jail he'd been in jail I
think for about 11 years and he was out
of jail for about 28 minutes until we
hit near Vicksburg and then that man
went back and that's the hound baby you
buy a wig you buy a stepchild you buy
whatever you want so hit the hotline if
you got a Greyhound story nine eight
five six six four nine five zero three
and this past weekend is going to put
together the baddest biggest Greyhound
episode ever I'm gonna try to get a
former driver in here if we can and see
what's what but thank you all for going
hound and you can find some of my my
tweets on Twitter hashtag thanks for
going GOI n hound and you can see that
I've been following ham but people
expecting Connor more people and gonna
get pissed off at a Greyhound station
everybody's pissed go to a Greyhound
station right now
I'll tell you nine things you'll see you
will see adult men trying to breastfeed
each other you'll see somebody drinking
a can of Similac a lady and she's
fighting with somebody on the phone you
will see somebody cleaning jelly off of
some bar at 100% you'll see that bro you
will also see somebody if you go outside
of the Greyhound look across the street
you'll see somebody probably lying dead
out in front of a building if you if you
go to Greyhound right now you go in the
bathroom you will see that somebody has
changed the locks and it's probably
living in there if you go to Greyhound
right now you will see that customer the
people at the front desk don't give a
[ __ ] about you they don't care they
don't want to be there they don't give a
[ __ ] and you will see them talk [ __ ] to
you no matter what if you go to
Greyhound you will see you will see a
lot of people that have just gotten out
of prison or that have a newborn and
those are the things you'll see man
thank you guys for checking out
clip and if you want to see another clip
and you can look at this clip or this
clip either one of these so did you pick
one or he's still just watching me do
this because this is alarming